for 200 years advertising has been the
backbone for funding journalism and the
newspapers and magazines had a pretty
good Monopoly on it the internet's
changed that completely newspapers and
magazines and the main organs of
mainstream media have been struggling
trying to find out what comes next and
what we are trying to do was to provide
an alternative to the dominant media
ecosystem how many how many people do
you think I'd substack or may keep over
a million dollars it's certainly people
making very healthy in the millions of
dollars a year you all take a stand that
it is free speech is there anything that
someone could rate that you guys would
take down all right guys bang bang I've
got Hamish here with me uh I'm super
excited to do this I thought a great
place to start would be on the current
state of the Legacy Media sub Stack's
always in the news you guys are uh
taking over the world you're a right
wing uh apologist all kinds of different
critiques but uh I think that you all
have a better understanding of the
nuances the pros and cons of the Legacy
world than most people realize so like
how do you break down uh the older
school media outlets and and platforms
what are the pros and cons of those
platforms today
probably was a huge question there's
lots of Pros it's good to have people
dedicated to the pursuit of fact-finding
and fact telling and storytelling around
narratives that help us build better
societies and for the most part that's
what everyone in these mainstream
journalistic institutions are trying to
do whether they're successful or not
um you know whether they have the right
approach or not they're trying to do
that
um
you know the New York Times there's a
lot of reporting and and lots of local
newspapers around the country do a lot
of reporting in unglamorous places and
about unclamorous issues
um
that wouldn't otherwise be done it's
really vital to the functioning of
society
um but some of the cons
well the business model is totally
broken uh the economics of the whole
industry is totally broken
uh it used to be the case that you could
go into journalism and have a hope of
having a good stable career now those
hopes that are really diminishing
um and so increasingly the people who
work in journalism tend to be from a
certain group in society where they can
afford to live on low incomes or like do
long internships for free
a lot of newspapers failing magazines
are shutting down freelance budgets have
been squeezed uh social media is
changing the way people think and how
the and how they interact with the news
and
um I would say that sort of mainstream
media is in a bit of a spiral there are
some large Global institutions like the
New York Times and Bloomberg and Wall
Street Journal and who are just going to
do fine they'll probably continue to
grow but there's a huge Halloween out of
the middle class and it has consequences
it has massive impacts on how we all
talk to each other and think together
and try to solve some of the big
problems on the stories that get told on
the stories that get highlighted on
stories that get swept under the rug and
I think we see the results of it in the
low levels of trust that the public have
and mainstream media at the moment I
think it's
the recent surveys have shown that
public Trust of media in the United
States at least is close to an all-time
low it's very low as like around 30
percent of people trust mainstream media
so when we think of these articles that
are getting written or the topics that
are being selected how much of the
quality in journalism is determined just
by the topic alone so when we see
um I don't know colorus award in
Afghanistan surrounded by the Taliban
War National Defense uh Insurgency like
these topics are very serious they're
very heavy uh if you are going to go and
tell them from the ground it obviously
involves danger and I think many people
as you uh pointed out uh would say like
oh that's journalism whether you know
whatever that means today that's what
they would say and then we see other
beats or topics that people may write
about and folks are like that's like the
most unserious thing ever like I can't
believe that X Outlet is writing about
you know why topic is that fair to say
just like sometimes the topic that's
being covered uh is different in terms
of the uh importance that like the
audience places on it and therefore that
changes the way people view like is it
journalism or is it you know something
else
it all gets wrapped up together right
whether it's reporting on the new Harry
Styles movie of the Olivia Wilde and the
big dramas around that or about like the
United States withdrawal from
Afghanistan it kind of gets called
journalism it kind of gets called the
mainstream media kind of gets wrapped up
with the the certain uh emotion that
people feel about the media and I think
probably in the most part
um what gets paid attention to is the
stuff that sells you know the the
salacious stuff the gossipy stuff the
easy to understand stuff the stuff that
you can consume in a tweets or in a
YouTube video that you don't have to
have any deep context on that you don't
have to be paying attention to current
self-history for
um
so
what I think
might be relevant in what in the
question you're asking is
people have a reaction to journalism
these days or the state of the
mainstream media and
um they're probably just reacting to a
certain slice of it and it might be the
slice that they just
consume most commonly or they see most
commonly appearing in their Twitter feed
and it's a filter it's not the whole
media it's not the whole story
um
what about the business model you
mentioned that the business model is
broken what does that mean
for 200 years advertising has been the
backbone for funding journalism and for
200 years the newspapers and magazines
had a pretty good Monopoly on it
because they're serving local markets
because they own a distribution and they
appeal to a broad enough audience that
they would get the major supermarkets
and uh businesses in their local regions
to buy massive ads they would have the
classifieds that would um account for a
lot of Revenue as well and people were
sort of obliged to advertise for like
selling their car or finding the
babysitter or advertising the death of a
loved one in the local newspaper the
internet has changed that completely the
internet is obviously the best place to
go if you want to do effective
advertising
um if you want to know who's seeing your
ads if you want to know if you're
getting value for money with your ads if
you want to have good targeted
advertising so Craigslist took away
classifieds from newspapers that was one
death blue
um then Facebook and Google came along
and did targeted advertising better than
newspapers or radio or TV could ever
hope to
um and so the the the big support
structure that helped fund journalism
for 200 years has just been completely
removed and newspapers and magazines and
the main organs of mainstream media have
been struggling trying to find out what
comes next like how do we survive in
this new world where the internet is so
much better at doing the thing that we
tried to sell for so long so when I look
at many of the mainstream Outlets it
appears that they are
expanding in a couple of different uh
Avenues around a couple of different uh
planes the first is it used to be mostly
all written content uh delivered via
newspaper they've now pushed into
digital but then also they're pushing
into video they're pushing into audio
like like you see the type of content
and the place in which it resides is
evolving and some of them have shut down
the old type of content or place it
resided but for the most part it's just
been added if they just keep adding more
and more and kind of becoming this
bigger and Bloated uh thing the same
thing is true of the monetization
methods so there's still tons and tons
of advertising now they're trying to add
subscription or they're trying to add
physical products that they're selling
in e-commerce and things like that is
that something that uh is just a natural
evolution of every business is like you
kind of dominate or use a wedge to get
into a market and then over time you
just add on more and more and so this
land and expand strategy uh is something
that is a natural function of marketing
markets economics and capitalism or are
they doing that because their previous
approach is like on a Lifeline like
they're literally dying as a business
and so if they don't do this then they
will basically fail and go out of
business and and it's more out of
necessity than it is just like
capitalism
well the ones who are failing to do that
or don't have the opportunity to do that
are dying the ones that we see doing
that and the ones who are doing it
effectively are growing and it's like
the New York Times and um I guess the
Washington Post has actually gone
through a harder time since uh Trump uh
is out of office because there's less
interest in their content now
um but with Jeff Bezos funding them
they've had a big uh ingestion of energy
into expanding their storytelling
platforms to more digital more video
more Community type stuff
um or audio I think it's a natural like
they're playing to the landscape of the
internet and with the internet there's
no balance there's no like you're not
bound by the margins of a printed piece
of paper so you can do video you can do
audio you can go Global instantly you
can be on social media telling your
stories there they kind of have to do
that
um the subscriptions uh is a the pivot
to subscriptions uh
is a must like the advertising is going
away the New York Times does have
advertising as part of its business but
it's a shrinking part of its business
now and subscriptions is a growing part
of its business
um so that's a definite business
imperative and economic imperative
and it will change the way
that these um
news outlets tell their stories and
gather Their audience because the
subscriptions business is different to
the advertising business the
subscriptions businesses
um more about delivering over the long
term of a relationship where the
relationship's quite deep
and the New York Times uh they're much
I'd say they're since pivoting to
subscriptions have become quite a lot
more
um obviously ideological
so they tell stories that resonate with
their readers and that readers want to
hear they still do hard reporting and
tell stories that not everyone wants to
hear but a lot of the stuff that brings
these people is opinion or features
where there's a strong point of view put
forward
so I think all these things are
basically changing Because the Internet
and the ones that were seen changing uh
the the giant success stories that
aren't going to day tomorrow because
everyone else is dead or dying and as we
see the content changing I saw a study a
while back three or four years ago where
they went they looked at the New York
Times at the use of certain words and it
had pretty much been flat and also and
it exploded upwards and the argument in
the study whether you agree with it or
not was hey when they went behind a
paywall or started to use subscription
it changes the type of content that they
write about because that audience wants
to hear something and if you tell them
things they don't want to hear they may
unsubscribe and so naturally you just
kind of cater to them and it starts to
build an echo chamber to some degree is
that a worry or a threat today to kind
of these journalism organizations or is
that something that you know it's easy
to call out it's easy to point at some
of these data points but we haven't even
gotten close to reaching a saturation
point where uh it's something that like
could corrupt uh you know all of the
mainstream Media or like how do you
think about uh the importance of that
who's gonna be we're it's gonna be
interesting right I don't know what the
ultimate judgment's going to be on
whether it's good or bad but it's
definitely a trend where people uh where
institutions and Outlets are starting to
play more to their audiences and having
distinct ideological positions and the
audiences
um go to them because in part their
positions are reinforced it's not
actually that new but like before the
Advent of the penny paper and
advertising funded
newspapers that were quite generalist
there used to be a lot more like a a
more parochial press where factions were
catered to you know back in the days of
Benjamin Franklin there were sometimes
One racer would assume multiple
political positions or and all that
creates one one person like Benjamin
Franklin would create multiple uh
Publications catering to different
political groups or different political
interests
in the UK there's much more of a tabloid
and Broad Street culture where the
newspapers are oriented around
ideologies or political positions
um but also social media is doing this
on a massive scale
as much as we might think of the likes
of Twitter or Facebook is public squares
they also sort us into our ideological
camps where we have the people around
our team and the people who are on the
other team and then the subgroups within
each team so that we get really sorted
into our own particular filter bubbles
it's a definite challenge for us to
overcome I think as a society and I
don't know what the um the ultimate
result is going to be
um but I hope that's uh with things like
sub stack and more niches being covered
more deeply that there are going to be
rewards for people who exhibit integrity
and exhibit the ability to cross party
lines and say things that their readers
don't necessarily want to hear and that
there will people there will be people
willing to pay because of that Integrity
social media doesn't really allow for
that kind of model then your times does
a little bit but they've become quite
strongly ideological
um
but yeah there's a lot yet to be seen
so when it's freemium or it is free with
ads uh we know the people who worked at
those organizations when they move
behind paywalls or they try to push out
into video or audio and kind of expand
their Empires do the type of people who
work at these organizations change or is
really the change in Personnel happening
because of ideological uh kind of either
differences or a feeling of hey this
isn't a place that I want to work
I'm not sure well hopefully with
subscriptions and with models that are
actually working in the modern day these
Outlets can do better and the sub stacks
and small Niche Publications and other
platforms can do better and can make
good money to support uh the the
journalism uh they're doing and to keep
hiring people who can come and work for
them and so overall um over time maybe
this leads to a healthier ecosystem but
I think the greater problem is not so
much based on um
uh like a particular business model but
um
in the last couple of decades probably
three decades maybe more there's been
this trend away from journalism has been
something that's sort of open to the
working class and there are like ink
stained ratchets going after tough
stories and sort of priding themselves
of being descend dissenters and speaking
truth to power to a different kind of
class where journalism has become like
one of these knowledge economy jobs
where it's um you know it's celebrated
in Hollywood and it's a little bit
glamorous and you get to
um have a interesting lifestyle
interesting life spend time with
interesting people and increasingly it's
become a sort of profession
that is closed off to anyone uh the uh
to anyone but those who have like Elite
educations or know the right people or
like hang out in the right circles or
have enough money like I said before to
be able to do a free internship at the
New York Times or Vogue
um or have enough money to be able to
you know have enough family money or
background money to be able to like take
a really crappy salary at BuzzFeed and
still live in Brooklyn
um and I think that cultural effect is
really large and maybe underappreciated
and it's been a decades-long trend I
always immediately jumped to this idea
of uh is it intentional or is it just a
byproduct of uh these Trends right so
for example uh if you take a bunch of
people who uh played college sports or
who were in the military or who all went
to the same uh high school or college
and you put them in a room what do they
talk about they talk about the things
they know and they all have the same
experience and we all have the same
experience then naturally there's not a
lot of diversity in in uh kind of the
things you're interested to talk about
for the most part and what I think
you're highlighting is like well if you
then put all those people into an
organization that is supposed to be
writing about covering and And
discussing opinions and and kind of the
thoughts and ideas and critiques of
certain ideas well then we shouldn't be
surprised that you end up getting a lot
of the same talking points over and over
and over again and so in some way by
driving out people who were different or
came from different backgrounds or
whatever it really homogenized the
content and when that occurred there's
an entire group of readers and and then
obviously of the population that say Hey
like you guys are crazy crazy just being
like you don't understand me you don't
understand my life you don't understand
what's going on here and that feels like
that part of this has gotten lost in the
conversation and doesn't really get
covered nearly as much as maybe it
should
yeah well I'll I'll criticize myself
because that's a a nicer way to do it
but I'm from an I have an Elite
Education right like I have a I didn't
want to I didn't go to big name schools
but I have an advanced degree
um you know I I think about intellectual
things I go to places with people who
are like me and I worked in the media
canceled you're cancer
and all that like all the people who I
worked with were quite a lot like me and
I you know I'm a foreigner as well like
living in the states
um
and we would write about our interests
we'd write about what we'd know what we
knew
and we had certain prejudices and
um we weren't aware that of of many of
those prejudices but you think about a
country like America
like I I look back and when I was a
journalist thinking like how naive I was
about what I didn't know America is such
an incredibly diverse country
and yet the mainstream media
institutions the main organs we have for
communicating journalism across the
country are all based in these sort of
enclaves in New York and San Francisco
Los Angeles maybe Chicago these very
like wealthy places with people and with
the storytellers that people from Elite
backgrounds
um usually pretty comfortably middle
class and above
and
they don't haven't spent much time like
in the foothills of Appalachia or um in
Alabama or Arkansas and there's some of
those small struggling places that um
get overlooked and they have
um not through bad intent but
um they have certain interests and
causes that are not necessarily at all
aligned or relevant to a like a huge
number of people in this country who
also have to like we also have to get
along with and understand and try to
solve problems for
and so
um yeah the the gap between the Haves
and the haves-nots and they have knots
in the states seems to be growing and
the people who work in the media are
definitely on the side of other halves
which which creates problems when it
comes time to like trying to empathize
with and understand they have knots and
trying to bring these groups together
when you all started sub stack was it
let's go see journalism was it hey this
is a way for writers to make more money
was it we want to read different things
like what was the impetus for saying
let's go do this because I I think
people forget uh entrepreneurs are
making the biggest bet they're spending
their time their reputation uh uh years
of their life are probably being removed
by by the day uh given the stress and
and all of that and so like what what
convinced you okay let's do this yeah I
actually resisted it because of those
things I was a reporter right I was a
writer and I just finished writing a
book and I set myself up for a career as
a writer
um which is difficult in different ways
but I wasn't about to go and become a
startup founder because that's a tough
job like it's you you can can't ever
really switch off it's under immense
stress I had been a reporter at Pando
daily a while back which was covering
startup ecosystems and we were telling
stories about these Founders who were so
deeply depressed they were committing
suicide
um I knew that was like a difficult
journey I wasn't that eager to jump into
that and make it my life but is my wife
convinced me that this problem is so
important and it's I'm particularly
interested in it and well cut out to try
and tackle it because of my background
and in journalism and then in Tech and
being an independent writer and sort of
writing about media business models and
media technology uh startups that had
not quite got there in the past
um that eventually I came around and
thought okay I've got to give it a shot
because substance could work and what we
were trying to do was to provide an
alternative to the dominant media
ecosystem the dominant media economy
which would come to believe is broken
fundamentally
um and it started when Chris wrote this
blog post he had been one of the
founders and the chief technology
officer of Keck which is a huge
messaging app um with uh hundreds of
millions of users and it's Heyday but he
had finished working there and he wanted
to write some more stuff and he wrote
this blog post and he sent it to me from
my um feedback before he published it
and in the blog post he was kind of
decrying all that was wrong with the
media ecosystem which was that because
uh online advertising was at the center
of its social media Giants had risen up
and created these new powerful
information systems that had us all kind
of addicted but the
types of content and behavior that those
social media networks were rewarding was
stuff that's like divisive and puts us
against each other and polarizes and is
sort of based on cheap outrage and
clickbait those are the things that
succeed in those systems and there's not
much to do with like quality and
truth-telling and as a byproduct it also
meant that the business models that
supported good journalism were being
eroded and writers were having a
difficult time finding um ways to get
paid and so who's left to do this
important work
and Chris sent me this essay and I said
yeah all these things are true but
people in the media know these things
are true what no one knows is what's
something productive what's something
what's a Better Way Forward what's
something we can do about it and that
led to the discussions between us he
never published that post that led to
discussions that became self-stack with
the sort of core Insight that rather
than monetizing viral content it would
be better to monetize a relationship a
direct relationship between a reader and
a writer where the reader pays the
writer they trust and therefore the
reader becomes not the product as they
are in social media but the customer and
then the writer can have a clear path to
sustainability by rewarding the trust
and attention of their readers when you
basically turned into self-stack so when
you think of that
um I think now you can point to and say
that thesis was correct people will
argue how big it can be what the unit
economics are how you attract writers
all the Frank [ __ ] right just throw
that out of the door the court thesis is
correct and that people are willing to
pay for content from people that they
trust and that trust can be derived
because this person's saying everything
I want them to say and makes me feel
good it could be because this person has
unique insights into a topic that I want
to learn more about and everything in
between right it feels like there's uh
quite a bit of uh different topics
different types of writing all that
stuff that's on there yeah when you look
at the things you got wrong were there
any parts of the original thesis that
you're like ah we thought X would happen
and we've been surprised that it didn't
manifest itself or or uh maybe we
thought a and ended up being you know
some variation of it but but we got the
initial part wrong
one of the gratifying things is that we
actually started the company by
publishing an essay outlining what we
care about and why what we're trying to
solve and what we're going to build and
then we follow that by building the
products and launching the first few
writers and they succeeded and we went
off to the races
um
we've got like we've we make mistakes
all the time
um the sort of micro mistakes along the
way of just trying to run a business
which and trying to run it in public
really because substance are very public
platform
but the core things that we set out to
do and the promises we made uh early on
have remained true throughout self-state
accessory and we're five years on from
uh starting the company now
and
I think it's been up we've been able to
like stick to those principles because
they're pretty simple it's like you can
start a paid newsletter or a paid
publication and someone can come and
read it and if they like it enough
they'll put their name on the mailing
list and if they like it very much they
all pay some money to help you keep
doing this work and to keep going
um we haven't you know we we've resisted
going into advertising we've resisted
building like a dick like addictive news
feeds where the content is sorted by
like engagements
um we've just stuck to the simple
uh principles of give writers ownership
let them have total control and let
readers have uh agency by deciding who
they want to invite into their brain and
who not to
um and because of the Simplicity of that
we haven't had too many uh
major missteps
when you all started I don't know maybe
I was one of the first 100 250 500
whatever writers on the on the board
yeah I think you might have been in the
first 20 for sure first 20 whatever it
was early and I remember talking to you
all and first of all uh you know that
you're early when the founder messages
you and it's like hey yeah I'm like okay
all right got it we're not at a
WordPress scale yet um yeah but but what
I think resonated with me so much was
there was a ton of stuff that you could
have done I remember some of our early
conversations around like what about
this what about this what about this and
you all were uh always uh consummate
professionals you would say like good
idea maybe later it was never no right
but but it was very obvious that like we
have to get this first iteration correct
how much of that was driven I know Bill
Bishop was one of kind of the very first
very large uh success stories on the
platform how much of that was uh bill or
other saying like this is what I need to
be successful versus you being able to
say like if we create a great writing
experience and then have the payment
technology like Bill just right don't
worry about anything else don't worry
about the product like we it works and
then the audience will comment and we'll
kind of go from there
yeah it's definitely a balance because
we're opinionated about something so
we're opinionated about subscriptions
being the thing to focus on and that the
writers shouldn't have to do any other
sort of difficult complicated marketing
or back back office admin type stuff
they should just type into a box click
publish and then money will magically
appear in their bank account and so
we're trying to build a system that puts
people on the rails to do that so that
they do the right things by default
without having to be
publishing experts
but also we've built very consciously
around writers and through
understanding deeply what they want and
it started with Bill Bishop who was the
first publisher on self-stack he writes
a newsletter called cynicism it's about
China he'd been doing it for five years
for free never seriously made money from
it turn on paid subscriptions with
substack in October 2017 and immediately
got to six figures of Revenue on his
first day and with Bill we're like
sitting with him in a Starbucks sort of
trying to figure out how to take group
subscriptions for him through this
proto-septical version of substack that
Chris the CEO of subset Chris best was
basically building himself and we took
Bill and we built the first versions of
substance completely around him and
there'll be some negotiations on things
that he wanted and things that we wanted
until we got to a point where we felt
okay so some of this can be generalized
now and we'll open the funnel a little
bit bring in a few more Raiders and we
kept on doing that and oftentimes we'd
find a writer who wanted to be the kind
of pioneer for a particular product or
feature and you are one of them Palm you
are the uh the prototype for you
provided the prototype for the
podcasting on sub stack you wanted an
audio feature to be able to do podcasts
behind a paywall
um or audio like readouts of your
letters and so we built the first
version of that for you
knowing that we wanted to do it at some
stage but not knowing when we wanted to
do that and so now you can host the
podcast on self-stare completely free
it's actually the
easiest way to start a podcast that
makes any money is to do it on substack
and you get all these other benefits
with it as well but it was like the
podcasting features are so great on
self-state because we first built into
serve this one customer and then took it
from there yeah what's fascinating about
this is uh so what uh what we're talking
about here is
um we I remember like it was yesterday
we had a meeting it was in New York City
and uh we're talking about a whole bunch
of things you guys were explaining the
business and kind of where you thought
the product was going to go and all the
stuff and I think I had a couple of apps
but the two that I remember uh vividly
was uh I said hey guys uh it's obvious
that I'm one of the early writers uh it
looks like it's growing the 10 fee I'm
gonna need less I need you guys to bring
that down and it wasn't even a
conversation you're like no like like we
are going to take the 10 and some people
would have read that as oh who do these
guys think they are that they're gonna
just you know be able to charge this
like what it was deemed at the time as
to be a high fee but I took it as like
no they know that this is going to be
super valuable and what they're going to
continue to put behind that fee is going
to only grow over time and so they're
essentially not negotiating against
themselves and it was it was I think
when I that was the moment when I was
like oh [ __ ] this is going to be big
like like they have a very specific view
of the world and they're going to go
Implement that view and then the second
thing was the audio feature and you guys
were like okay we're not going to change
the fee but like the audio thing that's
interesting like tell us more and then
you went and you built it and so it's
fascinating I think for a lot of
entrepreneurs to kind of hear in the
same meeting you're able to have a very
specific View and and be very steadfast
on things that you are not willing to
compromise on but at the same time
almost have like a blank canvas and say
like hey but these other things we have
complete you know feedback and
conversation with our users and then we
want to go and build this how do you
decide what goes in either bucket right
because I think that now that the the
user base is getting larger and larger
I'm sure you guys are getting emails
every day from writers podcasters video
you know name your uh kind of um content
type that are saying I want X how do you
sift through it all
yeah people tell us um we're stupid all
the time or like charging too much or
they're not building this feature or not
doing ads or not doing this thing you're
not doing that thing
um there's a ton of opinions but we've
got these principles that we're
steadfast on and one of them's uh well
one an interesting example is that we
don't let a writer charge anything less
than five dollars per month
um you can actually work around it if
you use a special discount that you kind
of make permanent but the reason we do
that is because writers undersell
themselves they they typically don't
think they're worth anything more than
two dollars a month or three dollars a
month and we're like no people are going
to pay you five dollars a month you
should ask for five dollars a month
there's a huge difference to you it's
not that much difference to them and
we're making that our minimum
um the same on the 10 like we know that
that 10 is uh more than pace for itself
it used to be just because we do your
customer support for you because the
Simplicity of the product saves you a
ton of time because substack you had
some basic network network effects like
if someone's credit card was in the
system you're only one click away from
from being able to subscribe there are
only one click away from me enough to
pay you and now we actually have some
pretty major Network effects coming
online through recommendations and
leaderboards and more and user profiles
so that now we drive
um more than uh more I'll see more than
the third it's very conservative more
than a third of all subscriptions from
substack uh on subset come from the
subset Network directly and more than 10
of the paid subscriptions so that
network is actually driving
um real dollars that you wouldn't have
otherwise got if you're publishing on
some other platform but we just know we
just know that we've got some principles
that we're not going to compromise on
um and everything everything else is
sort of product development and we're
listening to people we listen to what
Raiders want
um we're not trying to build we're not
trying to be a white label agency trying
to just respond to every user's every
need and therefore ending up with some
sort of Frankenstein product that's kind
of good for lots of people but not great
for anyone we're here to build a great
products and a great company and that
means saying no to lots of things so you
all I think probably get credited with
uh really Drawing the Line in the Sand
there is the mainstream media and then
there is the Independent Media or the
independent Creator or the solo Creator
whatever terminology you want to use it
was a trend people were starting to talk
about this There Was You know the Mr
Beasts of the world and things like that
but no one had really I think one built
a product to facilitate this in a unique
way and also too uh it feels like you
guys uh went from like hey somebody kind
of lightly dragged their finger in the
sand to like you got a shovel and you
really made sure people knew where that
line was
um how do you view the new world where
are we going this like Independent Media
individual creators uh world
where is it headed what is the North
Star what is the Finish Line on that uh
kind of Journey which seems to be
pulling away from in a different
direction than maybe the mainstream
media is
well there are some uh bmoths of the
mainstream media that will remain pretty
recognizable New York Times Wall Street
Journal their businesses are fine
they're not going to go away anytime
soon
I think there's the the attention
economy media players like Tech talk and
Instagram and uh Twitter and the likes
where they'll be like all the way down
one end of uh the sort of quality
Spectrum uh not to say it's all going to
be bad quality but other quality where
it's going to be like here's where I go
to waste my time this stuff is mostly
junk food I know I'm not like nourishing
my brain but I love it I'm having fun
with it
um and then there's going to be uh new
media media Universe uh where sub stack
is hopefully going to be a big part of
it
um
where new types of businesses will be
made and new types of outlets and
Publications will be created they
weren't previously possible with the old
model because now there's zero
Gatekeepers you can start a media
business on substack at breakfasts and
be making money from it at lunchtime
um people think that by the way people
think that's hyperbole that's you're
dead serious and I've seen it work
explain like the effectiveness of a
product that you can go click a couple
of buttons turn around and ask people to
pay you and you're literally collecting
Revenue within hours yeah it's well it's
part of that same philosophy like we
want people to be able to show up type
into a box uh click publish and then
money magically appears in your bank
account it takes about five minutes if
you want to set it up because you've got
to connect a stripe account
um
and you've got to tell the world about
it but yes you can publish a post within
minutes and then money will appear in
your bank account and it's really quite
a special model because the you're not
you're not dependent on like a an
Overlord uh to be deciding and how you
get paid and when you get paid
um and with self-sac the money comes in
on a rolling basis you don't even have
to wait to the end of the month and so
when you get a story that breaks out
when you do some good work that gets a
good audience or gets talked about a lot
you actually get a pay raise because you
get a flood of new subscribers coming
into your system and people uh some
portion of them are going to become your
paying subscribers and so you get
rewarded for doing good work and get
rewarded for doing good stories which is
a a feeling that's totally different
from working in a newspaper or a
magazine or any you know a new site
where you have to wait for the bosses to
decide whether or not they're going to
give you a pay raise and they're not
going to give you a pay raise because
their business is dying
um yeah and so we we're trying to remove
all the friction from the product
um to make that process as slick as
possible as easy as possible and that
creates a whole new dynamic in terms of
who's allowed into the media ecosystem
like what stories do get told what
communities do get served How Deeply do
those communities get served and that's
a pretty exciting world and I think
we're going to see um self-stack and
players like substack have an impact on
the media economy that's kind of like
um the impact of uber and Lyft on the
ride sharing economy like taxes existed
before taxes were a big business but
they're nothing like the entirety of
like the rates here in Market with Uber
and Lyft in there and I think that
substance can catalyze a similar effect
a similar enlarginine of their media
ecosystem new things are possible it's
going to be way more valuable than what
uh what we've lived with the last couple
hundred years
what percentage of people on substack
it's their full-time job versus uh hey I
rate this once a week I have another job
but you know I I do this because it's a
passion project
yeah there's well there's tens of
thousands of Publishers on substack
probably hundreds of thousands by this
point and most of them are sort of
blogging you know writing for free and
they're not intending to go paid or
maybe going paid as a one day distant
dream
um and then there's a smaller class I
actually don't know the percentages of
it but there's a smaller class who make
a make some pocket money they can go out
for a restaurant meal each month that
they wouldn't have otherwise been enough
to do
um and then there's some who are making
uh full-time livings or and or you know
good enough good enough income so they
don't have to take any other job
um and then there's someone who like
fabulously wealthy and I don't have
percentages off the top of my head it's
not that um different from other media
platforms where there is a power or the
big the big players at the top bringing
the land share of the revenue across the
platform but there's an emerging middle
class and there are things that we're
doing to help
um accelerate the growth of their middle
class and I think there are going to be
services that appear in the future to
serve this kind of ecosystem that will
also help that middle class
do we know if anyone's ever well you
know but uh
has anyone cracked 10 million dollars a
year yet
um I probably I can't say that
um okay that must mean it might be
revealing too much okay but there's
certainly um like people making very
healthy in the millions of dollars a
year on subsequence so that was gonna be
my questions about how many people do
you think I'd sub stack are making over
uh a million dollars is it like five or
six or is it like 50 people it's more
than five or six I won't give the exact
number again this is kind of um
something we want to keep under a hat at
the moment but it's a nascent platform
this number has grown fast and it's
looking pretty good and what's really
interesting to me is that some of these
people
um it's not a mystery you can go and see
who the top earning sub stack writer is
it's on the leaderboards on substate.com
uh it's Heather Cox Richardson hit the
cut Richardson she was she was
previously writing the same post that
she does on substack on Facebook for an
audience there that um just showed up
every day and like some trolls would
leave comments like giving this stuff
away for free she's still doing it for
free on substack but she gives people
the ability to pay if they want and one
of the Privileges they give that are
paid subscribers they can leave a
comment
um so she was making there's like lots
and lots of value created out of nothing
but she wasn't making any money she's
making tons of money now
um there are other journalists with uh
there are journalists who have left
really respectable big paying jobs at
Major mainstream Publications who have
left and quintupled their income on
substation in one case I won't name
names but uh increase their income by a
factor of 10. it's like 10 Tuple with
your income
um one of the things for me that's
extremely exciting because it's
unlocking all this energy in the
universe yeah one of the things that uh
I literally was just talking to somebody
in the mainstream media uh uh she's a
reporter uh we were talking about
something else
I realized hey may not be so happy uh
where she is and I just said you know
completely off the Record explain a
little bit more and where the
conversation went was like these
mainstream media companies they're
Brokers that's all they're doing they're
brokering the attention from the
audience with the work from the
journalist and the value that is
captured there usually through
advertising but more and more through
subscription or other means uh they keep
the lines here they keep like 95 98
sometimes 99 so you own everything they
own that person they own the reporter's
stories and IP like this reporter does a
great story that breaks out and changes
the world in some way they can't they
don't get anything if that story gets
turned into a movie for example other
than like a name in the credit line
well in some cases they might be coming
a little bit but yeah like um if you
work for New York Times and someone
takes the story and turns it into a
blockbuster sensation in Hollywood
you're not getting much money from that
at all your time is going to get a lot
of money though yeah I mean that is a
whole other story and and uh uh quite
crazy but but I do think what you're end
up doing which we see across the world
is you're taking out the middlemen
you're taking out the the rent Seeker
now it's unfair to say that it's just a
uh uh you know uh hand in the cookie jar
type middlemen because they're providing
Services whether it is the brand the
subscribers the marketing the operations
uh editors like all these different
things uh that obviously make it
possible
but it does feel like a lot of folks uh
believe that the economic value being
captured may not be uh sufficient for
the services that are being provided now
the reason why I say it in that way
there's a lot of writers who don't want
to be entrepreneurs they actually don't
want to run a business they don't want
to do some of this stuff and so you all
have experimented with a ton of
different things which seem to be those
things that everyone believes are
controversial from uh putting
essentially down payments I guess or
whatever you want to call like financing
deals for let us to get started yeah or
whatever so it's like hey look quit your
job come here we'll basically provide
some safety net for a certain number of
months you have to write X number of
times whatever the agreement is and uh
go and let's see how big it can get
there's been things that you've tried
around health care and and all these you
know other services where have you all
landed out like how do you get people to
do this who may not want to be an
entrepreneur but can't just only write
they have to do something else
yeah and subside model is not for
everyone right and for some people The
Newsroom model is the right way to go
like if they um they they need the
comfort and security of a newsroom
there's no judgment about that
um for those who can succeed with the
sub stack model and it's not just
existing journalists is it you know
millions of people around the world who
could do this
um
if they've got that oh I've got to pay
rent and
um I've they've got that hunger to do it
then their chances are succeed in a
greater than if they've just got a
comfortable salary to rely on so with
the thing that you refer to as we call
them substack Pro deals it's kind of
it's financing up front to help them to
take away the risk of leaving their job
or saying no to some other opportunities
so they can dedicate themselves full
time to the Enterprise of building their
own media business on substack so we're
kind of doing for writers what a VC
might do for a startup entrepreneur is
set with demanding less and we're
staying weight like it's totally hands
off we have no editorial influence on
those people or anything
um we did find some some when you do
that some people do shut you up for a
paycheck and they're like reading it the
wrong way because it's hard to get money
to get like any to do anything in media
um and some people show up for a
paycheck
um but some people take that money and
they're grateful to have it because that
lets them get started on building their
their dream publication or doing the
sorts of writing that they've always
wanted to do
and so you have to be quite careful with
the with the balance of it it's not just
going to be you can't just like spray
and pray and of course some of the deals
don't work out and some some work out
famously it's a little bit like um
funding a movie or finding a book or
funding a startup in that way
um but often what we've found is some of
the best earners many of the best
earners definitely most of the best
earners on soft stack never had one of
those deals they're just like backing
themselves
um taking the 90 from the start because
if you take a deal uh like that on the
financing package from sub stack you you
only keep 15 for the first year and then
you revert to the standard 9010 model
that substack has and those people who
are really backing themselves they can
succeed that it seems that they have a
like a very like a greater likelihood of
success overall and especially of like
out earning sort of whatever their
modest goals might have been and to make
a ton of money on self-sex 3
subscriptions
how do you think about the independent
individuals versus the people who are
building actual Publications I think
some of uh the folks who have done very
well on subject now have four five six
people and you know I joke that like
they're Reinventing The Newsroom uh not
but not like in a negative way like they
just realize hey that works for them
versus uh maybe Bill Bishop I I think he
does it by himself uh has no uh uh no
kind of team or anything like that like
how do you balance that and is either
one what you're trying to do or is it
actually part of the beauty of sub stack
is you could do either depending on what
works for you what especially works well
on subsets if you're a solo artist or a
small band but not necessarily like the
super band or the super group with many
instruments in it we do have some group
Publications that are doing really well
it just gets more complicated and we
think you'd be better off to have
individual self-stack than you then
Network together in their own way
um but it is really gratifying to see
some writers Beyond sub stack and become
so successful that they start to hire
people so Casey Newton has done this
with platformer he's just hired a a
fellow reporter to work with them on
reporting and on the business and
um dead legumes hired a couple of people
to help him on his his own publication
popular information we start to see that
happening more and more and I love
seeing that because it's the writers who
are in charge it's the writers who then
become owners and they're paying it
forward they're bringing other people
along for the raid
but an individual sub stack um while it
can expand to have many contributors and
there are several that are doing really
well in subseac it's probably better to
have it focused and then the way I would
like to see it play out is that people
build networks so you might have
Department letter and then you might
have another friend who's doing
something on ethereum and another friend
who's doing something on like defy and
you decide to like band together in a
way kind of like a multi multi-channel
Network on YouTube and help lift each
other up and maybe share some of the
expenses of editing or marketing that
kind of way and I think entirely new
types of businesses can be built that
way and we're just seeing the beginnings
of that on subseac now
uh I'm laughing you mean like uh if you
had the pop letter huddle up and the
profile and then you had this great
feature from substack where you could
recommend each other and when people yes
exactly yeah right on top of that like
what if you wanted to share an attitude
what do you want to share a lawyer what
do you want to share an art Department
um what if someone came in and invested
in your little conglomerate there to
help you like go on and expand and yeah
start covering wine in Italy and all
these other subjects um this to me
there's like that's a pretty borderless
way of expanding rather than I'm
starting a newspaper I'm going to have
these verticals I'm going to have a ton
of reporters and ton of editors and
sales team blah blah blah it's a much
leaner operation and it's full of much
more potential yeah it's uh it's
fascinating uh I want to ask you uh the
hard questions uh so let's just jump
right to the hardest one what will you
take down is there anything that someone
could write that you guys would take
down
yeah one of the things and and to caveat
this one of the uh critiques from the
mainstream media who the second they see
that we publish this they're going to
run and they're like oh let's listen to
what they're saying uh Hey guys uh it is
that uh
You all take a stand that it is free
speech for better or worse there's this
element of like hey people should be
able to write what they want and I think
generally have a negative view towards
censorship and stuff like that with that
said uh as with most of the platforms
who do this there's things like illegal
content there's things that uh may just
like from a society standpoint
99.9 of people reject as an idea or a
sympathy towards some sort of uh
ideology or whatever where do you guys
kind of draw the line or like what is
the framework to evaluate content that
gets into a gray area or or maybe
something that other people get upset
about
yeah we have content guidelines
um that are where the terms are pretty
narrowly defined
so you can't publish anything on
substack that incites violence
you can't publish uh porn you can't do
spamming you can't do doxing that kind
of thing
um and that's where the lines are for us
and it's
um
if anything falls into a gray area then
trust and safety team and the founders
uh discuss and decide like can I stay or
can it not stay but the problems uh
surrounding those questions
I think are a lot less acute for
substack which is kind of this system
where readers have control and they can
actively opt into the Publications they
want to follow and opt out of the
Publications they don't want to follow
in they don't have anything forced
against their will down their throat
um the problems for us are a lot less
acute I think than in the social media
Giants where there's these massive
amplification machines that are kind of
incentivizing provocative content and
controversial content and rewarding
those types of behaviors and so those
problems there are like it's a different
see the problems that they might they
might as well be different media they
are totally different media ecosystems
they may they may as well be in
different universes so doxing is like a
really interesting one because we've
seen the mainstream media over and over
and over again I'm going to say both
sides of the ideological aisle docs
people who run pseudonymous accounts uh
uh who have some sort of brand and and
then they end up saying hey here's the
person who's running it or whatever
um and if you strip away all the
political nonsense and the divisiveness
and all of that it's on one side people
like hey that was a doxing of an
individual on the other side is the
argument of like this ends up being of
public interest for ABC reason
so it's it's weird right I don't think
that we can point to and be like this is
the one rule that is always going to be
applicable because there's so much
Nuance in every single case but how do
you all think about that type of stuff
where it's like the mainstream media's
um maybe not response but like their
defense of something like this would be
like oh it's of public interest and like
actually it's not doxing in a negative
sense it's like journalism how do you
think through that
well if the journalist of me thinks that
certain stories do rise to a level of
public interest that it's clearly
defensible that it's worth
um exposing information or Shining Light
on particular information that might not
otherwise have been easily attainable
um
you know yeah there's no blanket rule
but I think it's incumbent upon the news
organization in that case to make a
strong defense and let the public decide
yeah I also want to call out that uh I'm
asking you as one individual and I
understand there's a whole team of
people who look at this so uh I know
that you don't have the exact answers uh
but I do I do think these are the
questions right people are like okay
cool if we're going to uh take the media
whatever that ends up actually being and
we are going to strip it out of the
hands of these organizations and we're
going to give it to uh a technology
company like how do you do that right
how does it actually uh operate
yeah well for us it is like there is a
legal definition of doxing and it's um
something along the lines of you know
sharing
um
phone numbers and I think private
addresses
um and if it's just a general member of
the public then you should be very uh
you should have you should be careful
about that
um but I do think it's it's not
impossible for even an individual sub
stack it to make a case that this is in
the public interest in the interest and
you have to take it on a case-by-case
basis talk to me about audio and video
what are you guys thinking there uh
outside of just writing everyone knows
you for the text-based uh kind of email
newsletter uh with a paid subscription
but you're pushing into these other
areas what are you thinking on audio and
video
um
I don't think there's much difference
between audio video and text in terms of
um what's the value to an audience like
the the person you know I've said this
to you before but like people are kind
of subscribing to you they're not just
subscribing to you the thing you write
um and so they'll be just as happy to
get it um or maybe a different group of
people would be happier to get it if
it's an audio or it's on video or if
it's just you in a discussion a live
chat that kind of thing and I think that
the business model there is uh certainly
can accommodate um the variety of those
relationships no matter what their
content is or no matter what the format
is so substack is like we've got first
class podcasting features on the
platforms free to hosts and distributed
podcasts and stuff you can have eight
episodes or unpaid episodes you can have
comments attached to it that go out with
a post where you can include other video
and all that sort of stuff we will do
exactly the same for video we have a
beta product for video at the moment you
can have subscriber only video that
lives in your sub stacks and the
substack app you can have a discussion
thread or if you just want to like have
a conversation with uh your subscribers
and
um
yeah I don't think the the actual
content type is the the thing that makes
it work it's the voice behind it it's
the distinctive world view that's behind
it it's the quality of thought that's
behind it and so we'll keep expanding
the platform to accommodate all those
things
so you hit on this a little bit earlier
but one of the parts that you all seem
to be pushing into that I find the most
fascinating this is me speaking uh as a
consumer of content this is me speaking
as a sub stack user uh and it's also me
speaking from like a investor
entrepreneur just like watching the
product evolve and I think that you guys
are playing a little bit of Chess here
is that all the features in the
beginning were one-to-many communication
it was very much I read an email I sent
it to an entire list yes there are
comment sections or whatever but for the
most part it was one to many podcast
same thing I record I send it out video
would obviously uh continue that Trend
you're now pushing into uh more of like
the threads type content uh chat things
where it may not uh be as much one to
many it could be more one-to-one or
maybe it's the creator of the
publication is just one of many people
discussing a topic an idea or whatever
and so it moves from that one to many to
more of like this like community aspect
is that something that you think you
guys will continue to double and triple
down on is this just a test like how do
you think about one to many verses like
Community type stuff
yeah well I think it's kind of there's a
formality spectrums right let's say you
can be in your most formal mode
broadcasting you could be publishing a
post or publishing a podcast the episode
or publishing a video and this is like
the thing that you've put a lot of
thought and time behind and you're
willing to defend it and argue it in
public and you click publish and there's
a moment and it's like all right now
this has been broadcast to my world
um and then there's the other end of the
Spectrum which is um something we've
been trained on for uh
decades now of social media which is
sometimes you don't want to have the
like the high bar of formality to me
sometimes you just want to have a chat
sometimes you just want to have a
discussion sometimes you just want to
hang out with people who are interested
in the same things you like and so we
asked them to do more work that enables
that kind of conversation and so we have
discussion threads which already exist
in subseac instead of creating a post
you can just
start a thread it's kind of like a
Facebook group post for example
um and in the substack app with pilot
piloting um uh a feature that allows you
to have an even sort of more informal
chat with your subscribers and maybe one
day that might be a subset of your
subscribers or maybe one day
um you just want to like you as a
subscriber just wants to chat to one
other subscriber from the same uh
publication universe and
um again I see the model been really
interesting for that use case like who's
doing paid chat a discourse I guess in a
way
um
not oh yeah like I I think there's like
the idea of having um
close High signal Community
um that's tied to the publication but is
not
um all of the publication is just really
interesting and I don't know like what
is ultimately going to look at uh what
it's ultimately going to look like but
it's going to be a really funny area to
explore this is fascinating because
um I tweeted it recently and everyone
was all upset because they didn't get
the invite to the groups uh which was
not my fault but uh I said look I've
actually found private group chats to be
way more valuable to my learning
information consumption uh over the last
couple of months than social media and
some of it is just like high trust
versus low trust environment if you put
something on Twitter and you got a big
audience like the trolls were faster
with their fingers than you know the
supporters uh and also more Relentless
um but at the same time uh it's a
different medium it allows for uh um
much more follow-up and nuanced
discussion and and kind of all these
different things and so it feels like if
I was to come out and be like uh oh
let's start a paid chat room people be
like all right dude like you know sounds
like a scam sounds like a paid uh
trading signals or you know like what
whatever the joke on the Internet is but
when you actually start with the
community of like-minded individuals
around certain types of content whether
it is the the written form audio or
video the chat now is a supplementation
and allows those people just to have
kind of more real-time feedback and
communication and if you could in some
way uh replicate these very small
private group chat value in the larger
audience like damn would that be
powerful right yeah I think I think it's
like it's very interesting as an idea at
least I'm I'm excited for what we're
doing here
um but I I do think of it as like
now everyone can have their own social
network
and what becomes possible when that's
the case even if it's just a small
social network even if the only people
in your social network are your family
um and we hope we acquired a company
called cocoon that was actually building
these sort of small community social
networks as well um and they are helping
us uh that team is helping us build this
uh next generation of discussions and
threads on substack
um and social media is completely
different like social media like it's
fun to chat in that real-time kind of
way and have back and forth and you can
find your communities on social media
but it's all a big performance and the
trolls are only a click away
um or a quote we retweet uh dunk away
and people get points in that game for
being mean to each other or for like
taking someone down in a spectacular
fashion in front of all their friends so
that all their friends can laugh at you
as well whereas in the
um Community the more the closer Tata in
that Community like you see on sub stack
people are there for
um similar reasons like I I like this
guy's voice too I'm deeply nerdy about
this particular topic too and if I'm
pain to be there that's an even stronger
signal like I care about this as much as
you care about this I care about this so
much that I'm wanting to part with money
to be here and that can create a whole
lot of um
great conversation much more productive
conversation much more good faith
discussion and I think that kind of
thing in the long run can have a big
impact on the quality of discourse in
society yeah it is um uh if if it is
possible to get there with a community
and you're able to navigate the spectrum
of uh what you call broadcast all the
way to chat damn is that powerful and
then also
um in some way it's fascinating because
by building the infrastructure it almost
seems like you all are sitting there
saying how do we take uh this group
which the initial thesis was like they
want to have a more intimate
relationship by removing the middleman
with the creator of that content how do
we just pull them closer and closer and
closer and closer together so that they
feel like they're getting more value
they're willing to part with that money
but the money is not necessarily going
to a media organization it's going
directly in the pockets of the person
creating the content uh which obviously
uh changes the incentives of the content
that's created that's kind of that's
kind of the magic of the internet like
the internet kind of started off this
way like in blogging days and in friends
todays and you know Facebook pre uh
advertising uh Twitter pre-advertising
they were much more much more um
authentic relationships and direct
relationships and uh people weren't
trying to game it in particular way
there weren't these engagement based
algorithms sorting us into giant tribes
and putting us against each other but
the internet like and so with like the
last decade of the internet has been
such a rough ride that we've all got
these sort of scars and bruises and you
know reflective uh like hesitancies
um but the internet can be amazing it
can connect people globally instantly
around particular topics some of which
are like deeply nerdy and hard to find
friends in other ways are hard to find
fellow Travelers and otherwise
um and so it would be interesting well
I'm very interested and hopeful about
what this looks like when the
monetization structure for this is not
advertising but is direct payments so
that really you are the you know as the
reader you are the customer you're not
the product you're not being game for
some other purpose and that the writer
gets rewarded based on how well they
respect your attention or the the
manager of that Community gets well uh
it gets rewarded for how well they
manage that community and the interests
of that Community rather than the
interest of the advertiser
um I think it can go through some like
fascinating places and I don't think
we've really seen the potential of the
internet yet because it's been
short-circuited by this other model that
has sent us on a a 20-year detour
are you at Liberty to say what the
craziest idea you guys have thought of
is
oh God we've thought of some crazy ideas
um
maybe one that you thought of but you
guys aren't going to do as of right now
I really want to get into book
publishing I really want
um I really want you to be able to click
a button and have a book in the same way
that you can click above button and
you've got a media company you've got a
um you know you you publish it you've
got your post for the day you you've
already written it that's the hard bit
done then you click a button and then
everything the post goes out into the
world and money comes to you and
subscribers come to you I'd like to have
the same effect uh with books so you're
a writer you've written a book
um you upload it essentially you click
click publish it comes out perfectly
designed it's got a price that you're
selected anyone can come to yourself say
I can buy it it gets distributed and
marketed to your mailing list
um it gets put in all the stores
everywhere and then you get the Lion's
Share the Lion's Share or the sales
revenue I think there's great potential
for that model it's a little bit uh
Beyond where we can go just right now
but I do hope to get there yeah that
would be uh absolutely fascinating and
you know we've seen
a bunch of people take their blog posts
their emails whatever and turn them into
books right so uh if you're the place
where that stuff lives uh it seems like
it'd be pretty easy for you to be able
to just scrape and say hey here's the 10
most popular ones they're this length
put into a book and do a little bit of
light editing and off you go don't you
know someone who's um Turned uh part of
the ethos behind this stuff stack into a
book recently uh I do Paulina uh I'll
tell you actually uh I don't even know
I'm telling you I'm here but um one of
the pieces uh of that process that was
fascinating to me is uh planner was
talking to a lot of other authors and a
piece of feedback that she got from
people who had published with some of
the independent uh Publishers with some
of like the big houses and then some
people would self-published was how
little the most professional of the
organizations did when it came to
distribution marketing and like the
actual selling of the book so much of
their process is focused on like the
creation of the book yeah and then
they're like okay we move on to like the
next customer essentially and I think
that that was
um surprising to me like I would have
thought most of the value of what they
were providing to people was like we'll
help you sell the book we'll promote it
we'll we'll do all this but it seems to
be that opposite which used to be a lot
more like that and they're not actually
acting in the writer's interests most of
the time they're sort of acting in the
company's interests and that is
expressed by them deciding to really put
all their marketing Resources by right
behind the books that are already
showing signs of being the winners and
so if you don't sell a ton of copies in
your first week then or the marketing
support will get pulled from your book
and put onto the uh the book that has
actually started to move some copies and
so the winners get really big and the
the the ones that don't have fast starts
don't get that much support by which
point like you probably would you know
you'd be better off just going your own
route and self-publishing yeah it is um
it is uh uh very interesting to see I
recently posted a video uh and it was a
a desk with a bunch of stuff all over it
and a computer and then over 30 seconds
it basically took all the things on the
computer or on the desk and put into the
computer so it took the calendar off the
wall and it was an app on the computer
it took the globe and then it was Google
Maps and like and it basically erased
everything off of that desk from 30
years ago and it was essentially
visualizing software eating the world
yeah what you're talking about is almost
uh automation like how much like how do
you automate the book publishing process
well the first principles component is
like well where do you get the content
to start and so there's not that many
companies sub stack being one of them
but there's not that many others that
could say like well we are aware some of
the content lives that people actually
write their books off of or they they
kind of create these Collections and so
you have to be a very unique company to
be able to get to the automation of a
book because you have to start with the
kind of source material
yeah the
I do think it's kind of similar to the
um software in the world metaphor that
you're using Zelda like a lot of
Publishers somehow book publishing some
hasn't caught up and maybe it's because
people look at the book publishing
market and see that it's so so much in
trouble that it's not that interesting
to them and like why are they going to
try and make books publishing as
efficient as possible Amazon's done it
with Kindle program that has its own in
a Kindle publishing direct program it
has its own particular particularities
and since their own kind of closed
ecosystem
um but to me it just it seems so easy
you wouldn't want to take the humans out
of it completely especially you want a
good human editor and a good human
designer or probably a good human
designer maybe generative AI can do
something for you
um
but then the marketing and the
distribution of the book and the um
getting into people's hands and the
price setting I don't know why you need
a massive publishing house to do all of
that anymore and I'm waiting for
um some platform to
unlock the energy there and
um just make it super simple for a
writer to publish they don't have to
know anything about design they don't
have to know anything about marketing
they don't have to know anything about
distribution I hope subset can be that
company but it seems totally overdue for
me
you mentioned generative art you did not
say generative newsletters or generative
words have you seen anyone do it yet and
do you think that narrative science has
been doing that for a while it's like
probably one of the easier things to do
right like come up with a piece of
writing that a computer can write based
on the data points
um I think I think we asked that to see
like generative at versions of that
um with fiction and stuff
um
and I think there will be like
if you'll if you're following real
estate markets or you're following
Sports I think a lot of the great stuff
to read in the future will be written by
by AI
um but I don't think that's gonna
obliterate the need for human voices in
fact maybe it even
leads to more demand for human voices
yeah I um uh there's a company in North
Carolina a couple years ago I'm gonna
forget the name of it which I apologize
uh to those guys but uh um it's got
Robbie and Joe uh it's probably
narrative science those guys are in
are they maybe they changed their name
uh it was like automated something or
whatever or maybe I automated insights
maybe automated insights yes that that
uh uh what's the name of the company and
when my mind was like oh [ __ ] this is a
thing is they had done a deal with Yahoo
for Yahoo fantasy football oh yeah yeah
every single game that was played like
if you and I were in the same league and
we had a fantasy football match up uh on
Monday we were on Tuesday I guess we
would get a report that was an article
written about how our matchup went and
it was all auto generated and I was like
oh my God they were creating like
millions and millions and millions of
Articles every single weekend yeah it I
don't care how much money you have you
could not recreate that yeah yeah
yeah and I think that this was pretty
basic technology wasted these standards
as well you can imagine the color and
Flair that are like uh like a really
smart AI might bring to that
um it's going to be an interesting world
yeah what what about uh taking like the
written content on sub stack and auto
generating audio or video or trying to
do some of that stuff have you all
explored that looked at your laughing so
I'm assuming that there's something oh
yeah like like Chris just sent a text
message about this the other day saw
something on online and said like what
about this there's probably so many
ideas and so yeah it's very much at the
like text message or slack message level
of ideation but
super interesting isn't it like can you
take a p take can you take a podcast
episode and with one click Market it on
social media through like the right mix
of audios and visual audio and visuals
and maybe text or can you do the inverse
can you take a piece of text and turn it
into like a piece of audio that you can
then use to market the the publication
or the story or even tell the story in
fact on substack already and you can
click the little headphones icon on any
posts and it'll a robot will read it out
to you a convincing robot with a nice
voice we'll read it out to you or you
can choose to override it with your own
voice in your own narration which is
even like a higher quality a higher
value item uh so yeah I think that sort
of stuff will definitely that's that's
coming
um quite excited about that kit can I
give uh product feedback live now and
you can you can tell it to the boss
uh I think it'd be pretty simple I mean
you have to build the tech to do it but
if people basically said hey I want the
ability to turn the text into audio with
my voice boys you probably could come up
with like a script and it's like hey sit
down for 25 minutes 30 minutes read
these words into a microphone substance
able to then take it build out okay
here's like the voice model and then uh
you just like drag and highlight the
part that you want it to read right so
like when I send the email I don't want
it to read the whole thing I just wanted
to read like the opinion piece uh and
then you just click a button all of a
sudden it makes the audio and uh and
you're good to go now for me yeah yeah I
love it save me seven to ten minutes a
day right like not not the end of the
world but at the same time it's like
those little things that get you closer
and closer to uh content creation that
is high quality but saves time and
increases uh money for uh for the users
I love it I'm not enough of a genius to
know how much like modeling you'd need
before you can get the the take Chris
like a little voice like one night
there's other guys that figure that out
but it's kind of like FaceTime you know
what is it face ID on your phone like
this make sure you like show you the
phone you're facing all the angles we
just get all your we'll get your voice
from all the angles until we with
mastered palm and then actually like
what do we need you for we just get an
AI to write your articles based on the
words you use all the time and then AI
to read out your thing and then you can
just go
we're joking but I I do think
um this is going to be sequential right
like now it's okay humans do everything
we see what the generative art like okay
[ __ ] this is cool this is powerful like
how people will use it is still up uh uh
for uh decision but like it's cool
yeah taking content that you just
created and then automating it into
other mediums seems to be like kind of a
no-brainer right and you see this with
people like uh taking audio turning into
transcript and vice versa whatever
but with the next leap which you're
talking about of like okay uh type in
one sentence and then it writes the
entire article for you I think the
technology is probably there where it
can create something that like generally
talks about it but part of the value of
an individual's sub stack at the moment
is that it's their unique thoughts right
kind of your point about like they're
subscribing to X person and how do you
recreate that it's not to some degree
like the creativity or the original
thought is the hardest thing for the
computer to do
um I say that and then somebody will
build a model and it'll like be smarter
than all of us convince us that it's
creative and original yeah yeah so like
it it does feel like okay we went
through kind of I don't know step one
step two now it's like very obvious to
see in the next year or two maybe three
years uh you'll be able to kind of Click
buttons and automate into other mediums
but the from scratch generation seems a
little bit further off uh and and
there's like weird ramifications like
there's positives and negatives to that
world that I don't think we quite
understand yet yeah we can't be too we
can't be too like the the rate of
development with this generative art
stuff is incredible and we can't be too
far off like 10 years from being able to
like
if you died right now
like I could load up my pomp app and
have a conversation with you that seems
original and we're actually responding
to me or at least I'm watching a video
message from you with a new idea based
on all the things that you've said in
the past or the things you've written in
the past and your image and you know I'm
gonna like that's that's [ __ ] up
that's 10 that's I'm sure I'm sure
that's going to be possible within 10
years and so I might never have to end
my relationship with you despite you not
being on the this Mortal coil anymore
the the other the other be crazy the
other piece of this that
um plain actually has this skill and uh
I've never said this to her but it's
like talking to a computer sometimes
like we'll be talking about something
she's like oh that reminds me of and
she'll pull out because she's just spent
so much time like this person said this
or this event in this person's life or
in this profile they did this or
whatever and what you start to think
about is like
Google does the same thing and like all
these systems are just mapping
information or data points and they're
able to begin to understand the
relationship between them and so a
writer what do they do they write
thoughts so if you're writing about
economics for example if uh you mention
you know March of 2020 when the market
crash like substack knows what your
writing was back then it can easily go
and see that and you have uh if a writer
is trying to kind of build an ecosystem
of content they're linking back to Old
pieces and like it does become like a
very interesting technology problem
where maybe you don't actually generate
the article right or the piece but can
you almost say like hey by the way you
just talked about this concept you know
reminder you mentioned this three times
in the last two years and then here's
the hyperlinks to the pieces right or
something like that I love that yeah the
machine the machine the system can be
prompting you but not forcing you to
include other like references to things
that you've done in the past or that
appear in other parts of the network
like oh you're right about
um you're writing about Obama's Legacy
do you know that like four years ago
Andrew Sullivan published this big thing
based on an interview he did with Obama
blah blah blah maybe you want to like
this this sentence seems to be relevant
to exactly the thing you're writing now
or do you want to reference it it's um
yeah I think it's like if you start to
um create a central Network for writing
like that then the opportunities for
that kind of Advantage present himself
and it's cool to think about yeah I am I
I completely agree what um what do you
think is the greatest critique a sub
stack when you think of all the the
critics that are out there what's the
one that you agree with or the one that
you're like you know what I actually
think that that's like a pretty fair
thing we're working on it and you hope
to be better or improve the product in
that way or whatever
I I think the um potential for audience
capture is a difficult and interesting
problem to work on so you know when
you're Shilling subscriptions people
might choose to pay because you're
telling them things they want to hear
and then you might get it in your mind
that you don't want to say anything that
they don't want to hear
um and I don't think this is a big
problem I actually think it's a worse
problem on social media but it is like a
risk like effectively you could be
running a cult where you might be a
charlatan or a huckster just like
selling [ __ ] because you know it's
going to turn into money through willing
participants who choose to subscribe
because they love to hear that stuff
um
and I think that's actually like an
education problem for society but there
might be some product design and
platform design things that we can do
too
you know help people connect with the
people who have high integrity ratings
or
um
make sure that there might be more like
you get exposed to more perspectives
than you might have otherwise come
across had you just you know followed
this one writer so I think there's that
there's not nothing to that critique
there are there is a risk with a
subscription model that audience capture
can happen and I think it's like it's
incumbent upon us to be like hyper aware
of it and sensitive to it
my last question for you is if we do
this again in 10 years which of course
we will uh what is the
vision of what substance has become is
it is there something different than uh
what the public would think
well I think one version of it is that
just could be like a vastly larger
expression of what it already is which
is this like network of Publications
where writers have direct relationship
with their readers and sometimes those
writers are actually doing podcasts or
video or live chats or like mostly
focused on community type stuff
um and I think the like tremendous value
will come
um when the network gets thick when you
start to get more and more
um readers and more paying subscribers
just because you're a part of the
network and there's lots of interaction
between from readers to readers and lots
of interaction between readers and
writers and writers to writers I think
they can get really large and that there
might be new
um sort of
um
supporting business models that substant
can explore and their writers can
explore within that for example
I would say that self-sac at the moment
has gone taking the media through a
phase of unbundling at the moment but
they're going to be new bundles in the
future
um and so ultimately I see
like a huge media ecosystem that's more
valuable than the ones that have been
presented to the world for the last few
hundred years and I see a system where
writers have a lot more control and
ownership and they capture the majority
of the financial value created within
that ecosystem and readers have a lot
more agency and they're getting better
experiences than they were given by the
media ecosystems that have dominated
today so I think it can be really rich
and vibrant and deep and valuable
I uh I I hope that world comes to
fruition
that sounds amazing you're helping
you'll help me make it happen man no no
no no no what uh where can we send
people to find you on the internet or if
they want to learn more about sub stack
itself where can they go you should
check out my sub stack it's at
substack.com there's a bunch of writers
there you'll find to love
um you should create a sub stack
substate.com sign up it's much easier to
publish things and uh than you might
think you don't have to commit yourself
to a big newsletter just write one thing
or post one photo or one video
um selfstect.com is the place I'd send
people to don't go to Twitter Twitter's
where the brains go to die
you're you may not be wrong my friend
all right I appreciate it very much we
will definitely do this again in the
future
awesome thanks Mom